au lendemain de france croatie philippe
rossi vendeurs de drapeaux a vu défiler
dans sa paisible boutique des dizaines
de supporteurs le bleu blanc rouge se
vend à merveille entre 30 et 600 francs
pièce pour l'emblème de la fierté
l'étendard de l'euphorie au plus la demi
finale en effet on est impatient de les
envoyer pour avant ils croient trop un
temps presque
et ça marche très bien depuis une
journée le jury les français se découvre
depuis surtout la qualification contre
l'italie
farouchement supporters d'une équipe
parée de toutes les vertus combatives
généreuse victorieuse la liesse dans les
rues de paris et de la france entière
réunit les supporters comblés femmes
enfants jeunes plongés dans un grand
moment de bonheur il est devant
l'assemblée que madame la ministre de
l'emploi de la solidarité m'a suggéré de
lever cette séance sur une ola même les
élus du peuple cède à l'engouement
national
le ton est feutrée la cérémonie
protocolaire et le propos grave c'est
que leur est historique
quand la france se rassemblent elle peut
gagner et que quand elle gagne elle est
rassurée et ça c'est extrêmement
on peut adhérer à l'équipe de france
mais on peut attirer l'équipe de france
pour des raisons totalement différentes
si bien qu'il n'ya pas d'homogénéisation
des catégories sociales et les classes
sociales qui adhèrent à et qui
soutiennent l'équipe de france en fait
il ya une totale diversité des points de
vue sur cette équipe et des raisons pour
laquelle on adhère la coupe du monde se
révèle être bien plus qu'une simple
compétition sportive un étrange moment
d'unité politique et nationale
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ni d'ailleurs jamais
été aussi haut dans les sondages